In recent weeks, you've posted why it might be unwise to do a water fast only with cancer.
I tend to research your previous video. So the reason why you don't want to do,
so the real thing is that you don't want to do a water fast greater than 24 or more hours.
And the reason is, is it increases IGF1 levels. So a water fast of greater than
24 hours increases IGF1. And that's the key. So you don't want to increase IGF1. That's part of your
growth factor, family. Now, we have patients and maybe people in a bunch of this that have done
a 12 day water fast, you know, and they feel like that really helped turn their cancer around.
And so I'm just saying this is a this is a de-hearted fast rule. It's a general rule. So a person
wants to do fasting and they really feel led to do fasting. You know, you can do fasting. It will
increase IGF1 levels, but there is other benefits from that too. It will certainly decrease glucose
levels. So there can be benefits to them. You can get just as, you know, nearly as good benefits
from time restricted eating. That's why we recommend that. So heavily eating that you're only
eating within a window of maybe, you know, cutting it down to three hours a day. You know,
I'm only eating between three and six in the afternoon. And that's all the time I'm really doing
by feeding cycle and the rest of the time I'm fasting. So you could get just as good a benefits
one could argue doing that, then doing a, you know, long 10 day fast or something like that. So consider
that. Is there a way to index topics on our weekly videos? We have talked about this as a team
many, many times. It's we actually have had someone work for us that have been cutting up the videos
into smaller videos. That's where you see a lot of the smaller videos. The course on the member side,
I think on the right page of the member site. It's just very, very time consuming for us to do that.
And costly for us to do that. We're trying to figure out if Dustin is working on some way with AI
to be able to use AI to our advantage to help do some sort of video indexing. So thank you for that.